my wife is the last person in the world
who would consider me a foodie type of
person she's always puzzled at why
sometimes I couldn't even tell the
difference between beef and pork when
shopping or
eating so a few years ago when I told
her that I found my calling in food as
impact investor she was shocked and
thought I had a midlife
crisis but the impact logic behind my
midlife crisis or midlife Epiphany is
simple given its size and reach there's
no way the world can achieve its climate
goals without engaging China in a
significant way this is why I've spent
much my career focus on supporting
environmental entrepreneurs in China
mainly in industrial space things like
energy or
recycling but I've always wonder
wondered about how to reach the vast
number of Chinese consumers I found my
answer in alternative proteins or what
we prefer to call new proteins nowadays
in China new proteins can be plant-based
microbial or cell-based alternatives to
Resource intensive environmentally
challenging animal
proteins let's look at some numbers
quickly China consumes 26% of the
world's meat and 45% of the world's
Seafood it's also worth mentioning that
China accounts for
43% of the world's poor consumption in
the meat
category this numbers are massive but if
you look per person meat consumption in
China is still low about half compared
to the US for milk consumption per
person is less than half in
comparison and driven by Rising incomes
and demand these figures can only go
up meantime Global investment in
Innovative foods with new proteins as
the majority were over $10 billion from
2020 to
2022 but China had only 3.5% of the
total at
$362
million I realized that investing in new
proteins should be China's answer
Chinese consumers can be a part of the
country's envirment mental solution and
by extension part of the global solution
to tackle climate change without a doubt
it is a huge business opportunity in the
long run as
well but how exactly how do we get
people in China to embrace new proteins
as has happened in other parts of the
world growing up in China I always see
food as integral part of my culture on
All Occasions big or small there's some
banquet
like when babies are born loved ones
pass away friends get together will beat
farewell to one another and we always
need so-called hard dishes in time as a
core part of this occasions meaning
dishes with abundance and varieties of
meat Chinese people don't just enjoy
eating eating defines who we are and
where we stand in
society as a Chinese saying
goes meaning that there's no pleasure in
eating without
meat meanwhile China has a long history
with Plum based foods which sounds
positive for new proteins but is
actually a
challenge old generation Mark meat
products especially have had a netive
perception with mainstream consumers
they are seen as cheap distasteful
unhealthy Alternatives and I'm more
intended to serve religiously vegan and
vegetarian
consumers environmental and Animal
Welfare advocacy groups have shifted
consumer mindsets in the west and eating
plant-based meat is considered morally
positive but in China mainstream
consumers unen easily seded by the moral
argument for
now China's consumers also highly
demanding regarding taste price and
convenience China is incredibly diverse
in terms of style of cooking and food
applications basically each Pro region
has a style of cooking there's pin
Cuisine Shanghai cuisine hang cuisine
suchan cuisine and cantones Cuisine to
name a few and unlike Chinese restaurant
in the US this Regional Cuisines are not
just different in the name they do taste
different to be successful and to have
an impact entrepreneurs can just come
out with a product that swaps out neatly
for meat product alternative products
will need to be tasty affordable and
regionally appropriate this cost for
investments in Innovation research and
development moreover we need new
distribution channels Beyond specialty
stores and vegetarian restaurants and
they must be widespread Nationwide
especially in China where online selling
plays an increasingly dominant role and
with Young Generation mainstream
consumers
it certainly helps engage high-end chefs
to put new proteins on their
manuals and this new products need
personality brands that seem hip and
compelling to younger
consumers new prots must also enter the
consumer Consciousness on a wholesale
level meaning the entire industry needs
good marketing campaigns entrepreneurs
need to support of one another and all
relevant stakeholders to gain momentum
all of this requires investment and
patience of
course the good news is that we're
starting to see some progress for
example look at the alterity diary
company oi the oi tea Master an old
based drink developed in China replacing
cow's milk for milk tea was introduced
to the Chinese market in March
2022 by the end of 2022 the product had
entered over 50,000 tea stores around
China with 20 m units
sold O's initial success in China has
resulted from its localized product and
marketing strategy investment in local
production and distribution Channel
expansion in collaboration with local
Partners meanwhile mainstream Chinese
consumers have been drinking all flavors
of plant-based milk because the past
lack of cow milk products I believe
plant-based drinks are low highing fruit
for introducing new proteins and having
impact in China more quickly and in a
more Capital efficient way Dow Foods the
investment firm I co-founded has
invested in about 20 new protein
companies in China and for China
products from Starfield Shing chiling
such as their pl-based tuna beef and
chicken are showing up on restaurant
chains and store shops across China his
clients include Sam's Club KFC Family
Mart and Chinese equivalent of Starbucks
lacking coffee to name a few plan
now a plant-based milk tea venture has
recently entered more than 500 local
convenience stores in chinga a new tier
one city on China's east coast and is
ready to enter another one Sil stores in
China's an province with their coconut
milk tea
product this Young Generation
entrepreneurs are trying to develop
products that appe to mainstream
consumers in every way equally important
they're helping overcome the negative
perception of pl-based products with a
new look and few and working with the
right distribution
Partners aside from entrepreneurial
efforts the new protein sector in China
is also gaining momentum on a few other
fronts over the past few years we've
hosted eight boot camps across China
bringing together and inspiring hundreds
of entrepreneurs who spend time learning
from the peers and figuring out how to
better their technology improve
marketing expand distribution and raise
more
money Chinese president XI jining made
some food related remarks last year
encouraging the seeking of new proteins
from plants and
microbes local government is getting
involved as well while municipal
government in China's young Delta Region
agreed to jointly develop a new protein
entrepreneurship program with us
offering office space potential funding
and
more I would love to see mainstream
Chinese consumers massively adopt new
proteins making them a part of their
daily diet I don't expect consumers to
give up on animal products entirely but
having more protein diversification and
choices will allow them to weave factors
like the environment and climate impact
to make more balanced and informed food
decisions
given China's Rising demand for Quality
proteins and the climate
ramifications climate friendly investors
worldwide should be all over New
proteins in China but they are
not many International investors
continue to shy away from China maybe
geopolitics is the problem perhaps they
un sure if they'll be able to get their
money out of China if they need to or it
could be the flaw assumption that
China's problem is so unique that it
requires Solutions led by Chinese people
alone but whether you're an investor
entrepreneur or a consumer if you want
to be a hero and Game Changer in the
space show me the
money even it's just one meal at a time
one product at a time or one investment
a Time China is indispensable in
addressing Global Climate challenges and
we should work collectively to make
China part of the global
solution let's all strive Beyond do the
impossible always look at the upside and
keep exploring the way aka the Dow to
get there for the one and only planet we
share and C home we must do it we can do
it and we will thanks
[Music]
everybody